[Música]
Olá, olá. Bom dia a todos para mais uma
live. Estamos fazendo agora uma live de
domingo de manhã, uma experiência nova
ainda não tinha feito. Vamos ver como é
que é a resposta do público. Sejam muito
bem-vindos.
Eh, seja bem-vindo, Irma, Wilton,
Nelson.
Me digam se vocês estão escutando bem,
se o áudio tá passando bem, algum
problema com o microfone?
Estou aqui agora com uma amiga querida,
Dra. Andreia Torres, nutricionista
brasileira, que já mora 8 anos em
Portugal, é uma das maiores autoridades
mundiais aí de dieta cetogênica,
entende profundamente do assunto, que é
uma dificuldade que eu sempre tive, né?
A gente tenta fazer parceria com
nutricionistas que entendam da
setogênica, mas como tem uma formação
muito precária ainda nas graduações
sobre isso, a gente fica às vezes com
dificuldade, né? Mesmo as pessoas
fazendo às vezes os cursos depois da
graduação, né? As pós-graduações em
medicina, aliás, nutrição funcional,
acontece das pessoas não estarem
preparadas. E Andréia realmente é muito
preparada para dieta cetogênica. E nós
vamos contar aqui a nossa experiência
que nós passamos aí durante 15 dias no
mês de dezembro. Eu tive em Portugal no
começo de dezembro para um congresso
maravilhoso lá em Porto, que eu pude
conhecer André pessoalmente
e a gente decidiu fazer uma experiência
muito legal. Ela me presenteou com um
tensor de cetose, um CKM que não tem no
Brasil ainda. E é uma ferramenta que
seria extremamente útil para meus
pacientes que têm déficit cognitivo. Por
que que acontece? Hoje nós temos o CGM,
a pessoa consegue monitorar o dia
inteiro a glicose durante os 14 dias.
Quando a pessoa já tá baixando a glicose
dela no sangue e tá na hora de medir o
CKM, porque na dieta ketoflex, né, que a
gente preconiza, Dr. Dale Bradsen, ele
pede para fazer também a monitoramento,
né, da dos corpos cetônicos. Só que
assim, a única opção que tinha ou era
furar o dedo, né, com o aparelho aqui da
Abot, o freestyle Optimum Nail ou então
o bafômetro, entre aspas, né, o aparelho
que mede o a cetose no hálito, que
também é difícil comprar no Brasil,
geralmente ter que trazer de fora.
Então, eu e André nós vamos contar a
nossa experiência com essa esse
monitoramento. Andreia vai dar uma aula
para vocês top aí sobre dieta cetogênica
e no final nós vamos responder as
dúvidas de vocês, tá?
Então é isso, boa noite. Boa noite não,
né? Eu tô acostumado a falar em boa
noite, né? Bom dia, Marilda. A Marilda
também tá dando um alô aqui, a Vânia
Pereira. E Dr. André, por favor, eh, se
apresente pro nosso público, fale um
pouquinho do seu currículo e depois você
pode já engatar com a sua aula
maravilhosa que você tem preparada para
nós aí.
Olá, pessoal. É um prazer estar aqui com
vocês. Meu nome é Andreia, eu sou
nutricionista. Eu fiz mestrado,
doutorado, pós-doutorado, tudo na área
de saúde. E ao longo dos anos eu fui me
aproximando cada vez mais da área de
psiquiatria nutricional, da área do
neurodesenvolvimento também. E durante
esse período, nesse período, eh, além de
trabalhar na área preventiva, comecei
então a acompanhar pacientes que tinham
uma série de desafios de saúde,
principalmente nessa área neurológica.
E o que estava acontecendo com esses
pacientes é que eles não estavam
respondendo às medicações,
fossem para depressão, para transtorno
de ansiedade, para Alzheimer, muitos
pacientes com epilepsia não respondem à
medicação e cada vez mais surgem estudos
mostrando alterações do metabolismo
glicolítico, ou seja, do metabolismo de
glicose, de açúcares.
Então isso que a gente vê como mente na
obesidade, no diabetes, muitas vezes
também acontece no cérebro. E quando
isso acontece, existem algumas opções
farmacológicas para tentar controlar as
taxas de açúcar no sangue, mas sem
controlar a dieta, estilo de vida,
atividade física, horário que a gente
dorme, fica muito complicado. E
felizmente a gente tem cada vez mais um
grupo grande de pesquisadores
interessados em intervenções dietéticas,
intervenções de estilo de vida,
incluindo a dieta. Então hoje o objetivo
é a gente falar um pouquinho da dieta
cetogênica, que é um tipo de dieta com
menor teorro de carboidratos. Eu vou
mostrar aqui alguns slides no YouTube
para vocês e vamos aproveitar para
falar, eu e Alan, sobre a experiência
que a gente teve fazendo a dieta, mas
não só fazendo a dieta, monitorando a
quantidade de corpos cetônicos na nossa
corrente sanguínea. Tá bem?
Maravilha. Maravilha. Já quer que eu
coloque os slides? Vamos lá.
Eu vou deixar os slides isolados aqui
para facilitar a visualização de quem tá
no Instagram.
Isso.
Colocar só os slides. Pronto. Pode
continuar aqui. Acho que você consegue
passar daí, né?
Consigo, consigo sim.
Perfeito.
Bom, pessoal, então o que que acontece?
A gente vai falar hoje sobre dieta
cetogênica terapêutica. que a dieta
cetogênica terapêutica é diferente dessa
dieta que a gente vê aí no YouTube de
dieta cetogênica, que a gente muitas
vezes vê nas redes sociais, né? Então,
aquela dieta cetogênica que a gente vê
nas redes sociais, rica em gordura
saturada, não é exatamente o que a gente
fala quando a gente pensa em dieta
cetogênica terapêutica, porque quando a
gente quer uma terapia, a gente quer
algo que beneficie o paciente como um
todo. Então, muitos desses pacientes que
têm obesidade, que tem diabetes, que
tenças neurodegenerativas, que t
transtornos mentais, eles têm outros
componentes além do da questão
glicolítica, além da da alteração da
forma de uso de energia no corpo, eles
também vão ter mais estress oxidativo,
eles também vão ter mais inflamação.
Então não pode ser só algo que reduza
carboidrato, tem que ser algo que também
trate esses outros problemas. Então, na
dieta cetogênica terapêutica, a gente
preza muito pela qualidade da dieta e
por esses componentes também
anti-inflamatórios.
Mas então, o que que seria uma dieta
cetogênica? Uma dieta com menos
carboidratos, que vai fazer com que a
pessoa consiga usar a gordura e produzir
corpos cetônicos. Então ela vai entrar
em cetose. E quando a gente fala de
pouco carboidrato, em inglês, low
carbohydrate,
existem vários tipos de dieta baixo de
eh baixas em carboidrato. Então, quando
a gente fala em baixo carboidrato,
sempre significa menos de 130 g de
carboidrato ao dia. E para vocês terem
uma ideia, uma refeição do McDonald's
pode ter 170 g de carboidrato. Então
essa única refeição faz com que a pessoa
não esteja na numa dieta baixa em
carboidrato. A gente precisa numa dieta
baixa em carboidrato, que o total do dia
tenha menos do que 130 g de carboidrato.
Então existem dietas com baixo teor de
carboidratos e existem pacientes, por
exemplo, que são diabéticos e se eles
baixarem para menos de 130 g, eles já
conseguem resolver a glicemia deles. Mas
outros não, eles têm que ainda baixar
mais a quantidade de carboidratos.
Existem pacientes também que tm
epilepsia, por exemplo, e se eles
reduzem o consumo de carboidratos deles,
que é, por exemplo, 200 g ao dia, 300 g
ao dia, para esse valor a menos de 130
g, eles já ficam bem melhor, com menos
crises convulsivas. Outros não. Outros
vão ter que fazer uma dieta de muito
baixo teor de carboidrato ou very low
carb, que também são chamadas de
cetogênicas. E essas dietas vão fornecer
menos de 50 g de carboidrato ao dia.
Para quê? para acabar com os estoques de
carboidrato do corpo e forçar o corpo a
começar a usar gordura como forma
preferencial de energia e transformar
grande parte dessa gordura em corpos
cetônicos. Por quê? Porque os corpos
cetônicos induzem uma série de
modificações metabólicas no corpo,
fazendo as mitocôndrias funcionarem
melhor, reduzindo a quantidade de
substâncias inflamatórias produzidas.
reduzindo a quantidade de radicais
livres também produzidos. E aí, gente,
tem dietas que vão ter ainda menos
carboidratos, 20 a 30 g por dia. Como
que a gente decide isso? Qual é a
quantidade de carboidrato que vai
favorecer cada paciente? Então, a gente
tem que acompanhar. A gente acompanha
pelos sintomas, vamos supor que é uma
pessoa com diabetes. Então, o que que a
gente vai acompanhar? Melhoria da
resistência insulínica. Se é uma pessoa
com obesidade ou emagrecimento, se é uma
pessoa com epilepsia, melhoria redução
da quantidade de convulsões diárias. Se
é uma pessoa com depressão, melhoria dos
sintomas. Se é uma pessoa com transtorno
de ansiedade, melhoria de sintomas.
Então, por aí vai. Para cada condição, a
gente vai acompanhando a eficácia com
base naquela, naquele naquela patologia,
naquela doença que o pessoa tem. E aí,
por que que a gente faz a dieta low
carb? Porque quando a gente consome
carboidrato, a gente produz muita
insulina e a insulina não deixa a pessoa
entrar em cetose, não deixa a pessoa
produzir corpos cetônicos. Então, quando
a gente tira esse carboidrato e faz uma
dieta à base mais de gordura, de azeite,
de abacate, de castanha, etc.,
A gordura ela eh gera uma menor produção
de insulina. Olha, muito menor do que
proteína e muito menor do que
carboidrato. Então, a pessoa com isso
consegue usar gordura como fonte de
energia e consegue produzir corpos
cetônicos para ter esse efeito
anti-inflamatório.
Isso é importante porque o excesso de
insulina pode fazer o corpo ficar
resistente a esse a esse hormônio. A
pessoa vai ficando resistente ao
hormônio. Isso está associado a uma
série de problemas de saúde, então
obesidade, problemas de sono, eh
diabetes, inflamação, comprometimento
imune,
resultados vasculares com maior risco de
doença cardíaca, maior risco de derrame
cerebral, uma série de problemas
relacionados à neuroplasticidade,
a doenças neurológicas,
a transtornos mentais também. Então,
quando a gente reduz essa resistência
insulínica, a gente consegue tratar uma
série de condições de saúde. Então, hoje
a gente já tem estudos mostrando o uso
dessa dieta cetogênica terapêutica
no tratamento de pacientes que não estão
respondendo bem à medicação, seja paraa
depressão, paraa epilepsia, pra insônia,
pra esquizofrenia, para transtorno
afetivo bipolar, para diabetes,
hipertensão, dislipidemia, obesidade,
Alzheimer, uma série de condições de
saúde, transtornos do
neurodesenvolvimento,
fadiga central, esclerose múlti
múltipla, alguns tipos de cânceres que
atendem, que atingem o sistema nervoso,
como neuroblastoma, glioblastoma e assim
por diante, tá? Então, a gente tem muito
estudo já eh nessa área, existem
pesquisadores muito interessantes
estudando essas condições todas. Agora,
o que vai beneficiar cada paciente varia
de doença para doença. Então, hoje a
gente tem um um consenso ou uma
uma recomendação de que a gente
considera um paciente cetose nutricional
quando ele consegue produzir pelo menos
1 mimol por litro de corpo cetônico que
cai na corrente sanguínea. que a gente
avalia na forma de beta hidróxibutirato.
Então, por exemplo, se eu comi hoje uma
banana, a banana tem carboidrato, o
carboidrato leva uma liberação de
insulina e a insulina reduz muito a
produção de corpos cetônicos. Então, se
eu for avaliar a quantidade de beta
hidróxibirato na corrente sanguínea,
beta hidroxid butirato é o principal
corpo cetônico, ele pode estar 0, 02,
porque eu comi essa banana. Quando eu
tiro o carboidrato da minha dieta, eu
começo a produzir corpos cetônicos.
Então, amanhã minha quantidade de corpos
cetônicos vai est 01, depois vai est 02,
03. A gente considera que uma pessoa
entrou em cetose quando ela está com
pelo menos 06 na corrente sanguínea e
uma cetose nutricional que vai conseguir
tratar essas condições de saúde a partir
de um, mas por exemplo, no transtorno
bipolar, a gente vê que os pacientes têm
mais benefícios com quantidades, com
concentrações no sangue ainda maiores,
de 1,5, de dois, de três. Então, para
cada doença, a gente vai ter uma meta de
concentração de corpos cetônicos na
corrente sanguínea, tá? Então, é por
isso que a gente faz a dieta cetogênica,
para que a glicemia, a quantidade de
açúcar no sangue comece a cair, isso
gera uma redução da insulina e aí a
gente começa a aumentar corpos cetônicos
para conseguir tratar essas condições,
seja pelo efeito anti-inflamatório, seja
pelo efeito antioxidante, seja porque
agora a célula que não estava
conseguindo usar energia a partir de
carboidratos, consegue ter energia para
funcionar. Então, por exemplo,
Alzheimer, que é uma doença que muitas
vezes a gente chama de diabetes tipo 3,
diabetes no cérebro, aquele cérebro que
pode estar cheio de açúcar, mas não está
conseguindo utilizar aquele açúcar para
funcionamento, paraa produção de
neurotransmissores, por exemplo. Então,
quando você tira aquele açúcar, os as
células do cérebro, os astrócitos, são
obrigados a fabricar corpos cetônicos
para alimentar os neurônios. E aí o
metabolismo do cérebro começa a
melhorar. Agora quando a gente tira
carboidrato da dieta, vamos supor que eu
tô há 5 dias sem comer carboidrato, eu
posso estar em cetose ou não? Vai
depender da resposta do meu corpo, vai
depender de quanto de açúcar eu tinha
estocado no músculo, quanto de açúcar eu
tinha estocado no fígado, quanto de
açúcar eu tinha circulando no plasma.
Então, uma pessoa que tinha pouco
estoque, ela entra em cetose mais rápido
do que uma pessoa que comia muito
carboidrato e tinha muito estoque.
Então, eu não consigo só tirando
carboidrato na dieta. Então, se hoje eu
estou há cinco dias sem comer
carboidrato, eu posso dizer: "Estou em
cetose". Não posso. A gente não tem como
dizer. E mesmo que a pessoa sinta algum
sintoma, ai, mas eu tô tendo, sabe, um
hálito mais cetônico, então já devo
estar em cetos? Sim, mas quanto de
cetonas? 06 ou 1,5, a gente não sabe, a
não ser que a gente faça alguma
mensuração. E essa mensuração pode ser
feita na urina, mas não é muito
fidedigna. Pode ser feita pelo arado na
forma de acetona, mas também os
aparelhos que a gente tem muito
fidedignos. E a melhor forma de mensurar
seria beta hidrroxibutirato
ou no sangue, no laboratório, ou em casa
picando o dedinho. Existem os aparelhos
que a gente usa para mensurar corpos
cetônicos no sangue ou então no espaço
entre as células, no espaço
intersticial. E hoje já existem
monitores de cetona contínuo, que são
aquelas bolinhas que ficam instaladas no
braço por 14 dias e que vão medir a
quantidade então de beta, hidróxidirato
entre as células. E foi isso que eu
desculpa sem querer interromper, mas é
porque acho que é muito pertinente de
colocar esse comentário aqui para você
falar a respeito. Ó, eh, olha o
comentário da Cecília, justamente você
tava falando aí da medida da cetose na
urina.
Que que ela falou? Eu não tô conseguindo
ler. Eu como menos de carboidrato, menos
de 50 g de carboidrato direitinho, tudo
pesado em balança de precisão, mas nunca
apresento cetonúria nos exames de
laboratório. Então é isso, né? Existem
existem questões genéticas e existem
vários ajustes que a gente precisa
fazer. Lembrando também, querida, que
tem algumas questões que não deixam a
gente entrar em cetose. Por exemplo,
quando a gente tá muito estressado, sem
dormir, produzindo muito cortisol, seja
por um estress físico, seja por um
estress mental, o cortisol faz o nosso
corpo pegar os aminoácidos da proteína e
transformar em açúcar. Então isso nos
tira da cetose ou mesmo às vezes eu não
estou comendo carboidrato, mas estou
comendo muita proteína e nós conseguimos
transformar alguns aminoácidos que são
aminoácidos glicolíticos em glicose.
Então além de ajustar a quantidade de
carboidrato, tem que ajustar a
quantidade de proteína. Por quê? Uma
dieta cetogênica, ela não é uma dieta
carnívora, ela não é uma dieta rica em
proteína, ela é uma dieta rica em
gordura. Então a gente tem a quantidade
de proteína suficiente paraa pessoa não
desnutrir, para ela continuar produzindo
anticorpos, hormônios,
neurotransmissores, etc. Mas não é uma
dieta rica em proteína, porque isso tira
também a pessoa de cetose.
Isso é uma confusão muito comum, né,
Andreia?
Eh, o pessoal confunde demais a dieta
ática em zooperproteica com a
cetogênica, né?
Exatamente. Então, eh, como que eu tiro
aqui essa apresentação? Pode voltar,
gente, a Alan, ao nosso nossa Isso.
Então, eh, muitas vezes a gente tem que
fazer vários tipos de ajustes, né? E que
bom que você tá fazendo avaliação,
porque a gente realmente às vezes tá
fazendo a dieta com menos de 50 g de
carboidrato ao dia, não está entrando em
cetose. Então é importante o
acompanhamento realmente de um
profissional que consiga, né, te ajudar
a entrar em cetose para que você vença
os as questões de saúde que estão te
acompanhando. E foi isso mesmo que o Dr.
Alan e eu fizemos. Nós instalamos um
aparelhinho por eh 14 dias no nosso
braço para acompanhar a cetose o dia
inteiro. E aí foi muito interessante
porque, por exemplo, o Dr. Alan, ele
entrou em cetose um dia antes de mim.
Então você entrou em qual dia? Terceiro
ou quarto? Em setose? Foi terceiro,
terceiro,
terceiro. E aí eu lembro que ele fez,
ele me falou, ele me mandou uma
mensagem, entrei em cetos e aí eu falei
para ele, eu devo estar entrando amanhã
ou depois, né? Por quê? Porque mulheres,
pela questão hormonal que é diferente
dos homens, pela menor massa muscular em
relação aos homens, geralmente levam
mais tempo para entrar em cetose. Então,
por exemplo, eu faço, eu não tenho
nenhuma doença, tá, gente? Mas eu faço
protocolos de dieta cetogênica duas
vezes ao ano. Uma vez em dezembro, antes
de Natal e Ano Novo, e uma vez no meio
do ano, né, para aumentar, né, essa
limpeza do corpo, do cérebro, tal. Eh,
então duas vezes ao ano eu faço isso
mesmo não tendo nenhuma condição de
saúde importante. E então eu já sei,
como eu já faço isso algum algum tempo,
dependendo da quantidade de carboidrato
que eu estava consumindo antes do car do
do protocolo, eu posso levar 4, 5, 6, 7
dias para entrar em cetose, fazendo tudo
direitinho, monitorando tudo, tomando
TCM, que é o triglicerid de cadeia
média, tomando eletrólitos, né,
acompanhando tudo bonitinho, né? Então,
nesse nesse nessa experiência que eu fiz
com a Alan, ele entrou e eu entrei um
dia depois.
É, mas com certeza você ficou mais tempo
em Setos do que eu no geral, porque isso
foi uma coisa que me chocou muito, né?
Até comentei com o Andreia teve um dia,
primeiro que quando eu voltei de
Portugal tinha muita coisa acumulada e
eu não consegui na academia naquela
semana em seguida. Então eu percebi que
a falta de atividade física me
dificultou, né? Talvez o cortisol, que
eu não medi o cotisol, mas eu acho que
eu tava um pouco
agitado naquela semana que eu voltei, é
coisa acumulada. Eu acho que atrapalhou
entrar em cetose também. Mas uma coisa
que comentei com ela que me chocou
muito, eu tava com um, né, de copo cetô
de betrox butirato, tinha acabado de
voltar de uma atividade física na
esteira, 5 km.
E aí eu fui comer um tomate, eu tava
morrendo de fome, já tinha acho que umas
eh sei lá quantas horas, tinha umas 10
horas que eu tava sem comer. Eu tava
podre de fome e falei: "Vou comer um
tomate que não é possível que o tomate
não vai me tirar, ele não vai me tirar
dessa tose, né?" Falei, não tem 3 ou 4 g
de carboidrato nesse troço, não é
possível. Eu foi comer o tomate, a o
beta hidróxid butirado foi de um para
03, uma coisa assim, eu fiquei
revoltado. Aí eu eu entrei em contato
com a André, não é possível que tá
acontecendo? Aí ela falou: "Não é porque
você tinha que estar comendo gordura
junto".
Eu queria que você comentar sobre isso.
É exatamente. Então, gente, tem vários
aspectos. Além de a dieta não ter mais
do que 20 a 50 g de carboidrato ao dia,
a gente tem que pensar em cada refeição
também. Então, o que que é uma refeição
cetogênica? É uma refeição que sempre
vai ter pelo menos a mesma quantidade de
gordura em relação a carboidrato e
proteína. Então, se o tomate que ele
comeu tem 4 g de carboidrato e o tomate
que ele comeu também tem o qu de
proteína? Acho que tem 1 g de proteína.
Então, a soma de carboidrato, 4 g de
carboidrato mais 1 g de proteína, 5 g.
Quatro de carboidrato e um de proteína.
Então, se eu tenho nessa soma
carboidrato mais proteína 5 g, eu tenho
que ter de gordura pelo menos a mesma
quantidade, 5 g de gordura, entendeu?
Para não sair da cetose. E tem pessoas,
e aí que é o ajuste, né, gente? Por isso
que a gente tem que medir. E aí que vem
o ajuste. Então, para ele, que que
significa comer a mesma quantidade de
gordura em relação a carboidrata mais
proteína? Significa que essa dieta é uma
dieta cetogênica um para um, a mesma
quantidade de gordura em relação à soma,
carboidrato e proteína. Então, se ele
tivesse comido 5 g de carboidrato e
proteína do tomate, mais 5 g de gordura,
tivesse mantido a cetonemia dele, para
ele tava OK. Mas vamos supor que mesmo
assim ele saiu de cetose ou a cetose
baixou. Então, de repente tem que ser
uma dieta 1,5 para um. tem 1,5 a mais de
gordura em relação a carboidrato para
proteína. Aí mesmo assim minha cetose
baixou. Então às vezes tem que ser dois
para um, o dobro de gordura em relação a
carboidrato mais proteína ou três para
um ou quatro para um. Isso varia de
pessoa para pessoa, porque o nosso
metabolismo, a forma como as nossas
mitocôndrias estão respondendo, a saúde
dessas mitocôndrias também varia de
pessoa para pessoa, varia com a nossa
idade, varia com o nosso nível de
atividade física, com o nosso nível de
estress, com a nossa genética e por aí
vai. Então esse acompanhamento é muito
importante pra gente ter esse ajuste
fino e
conseguir manter o paciente em cetose.
Olha só a pergunta aqui do Caled, não
sei se é a Caled ou o Caled, você falou
isso na aula, mas era bom você até
completar um pouquinho. Talvez ele tem
alguém na família com a condição aí da
esquizofrenia.
Uhum. Então, exatamente. Agora já tem,
vou até botar aqui um um estudo na tela
de esquizofrenia. Vocês sabem que um dos
meus interesses na na dieta cetogênica
foi justamente a esquizofrenia, porque
meu avô tinha diagnóstico diagnóstico de
esquizofrenia e antigamente não se
falava disso, né? Então, eh, hoje,
felizmente, já tem estudos em relação a
vários tipos de transtornos mentais,
inclusive a esquizofrenia. Então, esse
aqui, por exemplo, olha, é um artigo que
foi publicado agora 2025 sobre o papel
da terapia cetogênica na esquizofrenia.
Estão sendo feitos cada vez mais estudos
nessa área, tá, de saúde mental. E nesse
estudo eles discutiram alguns papéis.
Então, por exemplo, eu falei para vocês,
olha, a dieta cetogênica, ela tem
algumas funções anti-inflamatórias,
antioxidantes. Então eles já estão
mostrando, né, nos estudos pré-clínicos
que a dieta cetogênica vai antagonizar
receptores NMDA, que são receptores
muito excitatórios pro cérebro, eh vão
melhorar comportamento, vão tratar,
olha, a função mitocondrial, vão modular
neurotransmissores como gaba, glutamina,
dopamina, reduzir a inflamação no
cérebro, reduzir o estess oxidativo.
Então, essas disfunções na
esquizofrenia, principalmente aquele
paciente que não tá conseguindo ser
tratado apenas com os fármacos, elas,
quando a gente combina com a dieta
cetogênica, o paciente tem uma resposta
melhor, tá? Então, muito interessante
também eh nos transtornos mentais a
gente tá tendo cada vez mais estudos.
Ano passado saíram alguns estudos na
depressão, saíram alguns estudos no
transtorno bipolar. Alguém tá
perguntando aqui sobre dieta cetogênica.
A Aninha, eh, no câncer, o câncer não é
uma uma doença, né, gente? Existem
milhares de tipos de cânceres. Então,
existem alguns cânceres que respondem
muito bem a dieta cetogênica e outros
não. Por isso
s isso é muito importante, sabe, André?
Porque o que acontece? Eh, existe uma
ideia que é propagada há muitos anos que
é parcialmente correta sobre a o efeito
Warberg, né,
que a maioria dos cânceres realmente
fazem a glicólise
eh, sem utilizar o oxigênio, mesmo no
ambiente rico em oxigênio, né? Então, a
célula tumoral, na maioria das vezes,
ela não, ela desliga a mitocôndria e faz
a glicólise pura, né, sem utilizar a
cascata fosfolilativa da da mitocôndria.
E aí as pessoas tomaram isso como
verdade absoluta, mas existe vários
estudos já que eu já levantei essa
literatura mostrando que tem tumores sim
que fazem metabolismo de ácidos gros ou
de corpos cetônicos.
E o câncer espertinho, sabe? O câncer é
muito espertinho, sabe, gente? Ele vai
mudando o metabolismo conforme ele
precisa sobreviver. Ele vai passando de
um substrato por outro. Ele tava usando
carboidrato, você tira o carboidrato,
ele começa a usar gordura. Aí você tira
gordura, ele começa a usar proteína. Ele
é inteligente esse bicho. Por isso que
fala,
grosseiramente falando, tá gente?
Grosseiramente falando, 80% dos tumores
são glicogênicos, assim, faz a glicólise
em ambiente de alta alto oxigênio.
Glicólise que seria anaeróbica, mas na
verdade é aeróbica porque tem oxigênio
junto, só que ele não usa oxigênio, né?
É um termo meio confuso inclusive, mas
existe uns 20% aí que não vai responder
a dieta cetogênica, grosseiramente
falando, tá? Isso vai variar de estudo
para estudo. Então tem os tipos de
cânceres que são muito de muito difícil
de tratamento comum como alguns cânceres
no cérebro que a gente tem resultados
muito positivos de melhoria, né, de do
tratamento, da resposta ao tratamento
quimioterápico ou radioterápico com a
dieta cetogênica, mas realmente, né, tem
que ter um acompanhamento muito grande
da equipe toda, né, não só do do da
nutricionista, mas do oncologista e do
restante da equipe pra gente ir
analisando esse metabolismo.
Existem estudos metabolômicos que a
gente pode ir fazendo para acompanhar o
que que tá acontecendo nesse metabolismo
e tomando decisões também. Agora,
independente da dieta, Aninha, que a
pessoa tá fazendo durante o tratamento
do câncer, a gente sabe o seguinte, que
depois do tratamento a gente tem que
continuar cuidando. Por quê? Porque o
tratamento convencional como
quimioterápico, ele causa um estrago
também metabólico, né? O quimioterápico,
ele vai tentar matar o câncer, mas ele
acaba gerando uma zona no organismo e o
paciente sai todo inflamado e a gente
tem que continuar tratando. Então, os
exames metabolômicos depois que o
paciente já recebeu alta do câncer,
valem muito a pena pra gente analisar
como esse como tá esse metabolismo e
para avaliar se a dieta cetogênica
inclusive continua valendo a pena para
esse paciente, apesar dele já ter
recebido alta do tratamento até para
evitar recidiva 10 anos, 20 anos, 30
anos depois, tá?
No caso seria os ácidos orgânicos
urinários basicamente, né, dos
metabolos. Exatamente. Exatamente.
Perfeito.
A gente vê muito assim, o paciente sai
do tratamento do câncer e o, por
exemplo, 8 HDG altíssimo ainda, que é
aquele marcador, por exemplo, de estress
oxidativo no DNA ou outros marcadores de
disfunção mitocondrial. Então, muito
interessante avaliar também depois do
tratamento.
Com certeza. Associado jejum
intermitente potencialista. Com certeza.
Aí a doutora vai falar mais a respeito
agora. Olha, foi super interessante essa
pergunta porque até o Dr. Alan passou
por isso. Ele precisou fazer jejum, já
que ele não tava conseguindo ir pra
academia para conseguir manter a cetose,
né? Então o que que acontece? Existem
várias formas de promover a cetose. Uma
é o jejum. Então gente, cetose não é uma
coisa assim alienígena. Cetose é uma
coisa que todo mundo faz. A gente ficou
sem comer, precisa de energia, a gente
produz corpos cetônicos. Os
recém-nascidos fazem isso, tá? Então, o
recém-nascido nasce, não tá conseguindo
mamar ainda, ele tá sobrevivendo,
produzindo corpos cetônicos. Então, a
gente faz sempre, recém-nascido faz,
todo mundo faz. Eh, então é uma forma de
fornecer de forma alternativa energia
pro nosso corpo. Então, quando a gente
não come, não tem carboidrato entrando,
eu vou precisar usar outra coisa como
fonte de energia. Então, gordura. E
quando a gente tá usando gordura, uma
parte disso é convertida em corpos
cetônicos. Outra forma, né, é a dieta
cetogênica, uma dieta com muito pouco
carboidrato. Então, não tô com tô não tô
fazendo jejum, mas tô comendo muito
pouco carboidrato e preciso que parte da
energia venha da gordura e dos corpos
cetônicos. Outra forma são eh
suplementos de corpos cetônicos. Então
eles já existem corpos cetônicos
exógenos que facilitam também essa
entrada em cetose, suplementos de
triglicerídeos de cadeia média, que são
gorduras de 8 a 10 carbonos, gente.
Então, por exemplo, quando a gente come
manteiga, carne, eh, azeite, óleo de
soja, todas essas são gorduras grandes
de mais de 20 carbonos. E essas gorduras
de mais de 20 carbonos, elas têm mais
dificuldade de serem convertidas em
corpos cetônicos. Existem gorduras
menores, que a gente chama de
triglicerídeo de cadeia média C8,
principalmente o ácido caprílico, que é
facilmente convertido pelo fígado e pelo
cérebro em corpos cetônicos, tá? Então a
gente usa também muito suplemento de
TCM, triglicerido, cadia média,
especificamente o C8, para facilitar
essa cetose, outra forma maravilhosa.
Mas vão existir cada vez mais
suplementos. Então os os suplementos de
corpos cetônicos ainda não foram
liberados no Brasil, mas já foram
liberados nos Estados Unidos, em alguns
países da Europa, na Polônia, no Reino
Unido, na Austrália,
é aqui no Brasil eh existe já há alguns
anos o Gol BHB e semelhantes que são da
manipulação, né?
É, são butiratos, né? Não são
isso é aquele mesmo butirato, na verdade
de quatro carbonos que é produzido lá no
intestino,
tá? Não é o C8, é, não é o C8, isso não
é o C8, é o C4, tá? Que é o mesmo que
nosso intestino. E aí outro ponto
importante, alguém falou aí: "Nossa, eu
não consigo entrar em cetose". Como é
que tá esse intestino? O intestino tem
que trabalhar pra gente também, tá?
Então o intestino vai produzir também
ácidos grásos cadeia curta que, né, vão
ter função reguladora epigenética, tá? E
vão ajudar nesse processo. Eh, então
essas são as principais formas, dieta
cetogênica, jejum, a atividade física
ajuda muito, porque quando a gente faz
atividade física, o nosso músculo acaba
com nossa reserva de glicose, aí ele vai
ter que usar outra coisa, né? E aí, sabe
aqueles aqueles maratonistas, gentes da
África que correm sem comer nada durante
a prova? Porque a gente vê, né, os
ocidentais aí, toma gel de carboidrato,
toma isso, toma gator, toma tudo e
aqueles caras correm a maratona toda sem
usar nenhum suplemento. Por quê? Porque
eles estão setoadaptados. Eles são dessa
finura, eles não têm muita reserva de
nada. Eles correm a prova toda sem eh
sem suplemento.
É aquela galera que você tem vontade de
levar para casa, dar comida para ele,
né? Você com pena dele, né?
Exatamente. Porque eles estão
setoadaptados, eles conseguem
fornecer muita energia por um músculo à
base de corpos cetônicos e terminar a
prova assim, né? E isso é importante
também, gente. Existe uma setoadaptação.
Por isso que no início da dieta
cetogênica, muita gente fala: "Ah, eu tô
com dor de cabeça, eu tô com cansaço, eu
tô com mau humor, eu tô dormindo mal e
tal". E aí depois de alguns dias a
pessoa vai se adaptando, as mitocôndrias
vão aprendendo a usar esses corpos
cetônicos e vai ficando mais fácil. A,
sabe aquela pessoa assim que ela não
pode pular uma refeição que ela quase
morre? é a pessoa que tá com a, a gente
fala que tá com a mitocôndria mimada, é
aquela pessoa que fica comendo o dia
todo, né? Pãozinho, biscoitinho,
bolinho, fica beliscando o dia todo
e o corpo desaprende a usar gordura,
porque a gente tá o tempo todo
fornecendo carboidrato. Aí aí a a
mitocôndria fica mimada, ela só quer
usar carboidrato porque é muito fácil.
Só que na hora que a mitocôndria fica
disfuncional,
ela não consegue usar carboidrato e ela
desaprendeu a usar as outras coisas. Aí
a pessoa fica uma hora sem comer, ela
fala: "Ai, meu Deus, eu não tenho
energia". A pessoa tá obesa, ou seja,
ela tem muita energia acumulada e não
consegue ficar sem comer, né? Começa a
passar mal, né? Então, a gente
tem muita hipoglicemia reativa ou
reacional, né? Exato. Então, para essa
pessoa no início vai ser mais fácil, tem
que treinar essa mitocôndria de novo.
Por isso que a maioria dos estudos, por
exemplo, na área de saúde mental, fala
que é paraa pessoa começar a sentir os
efeitos nessas doenças específicas, ela
tem que fazer a dieta por pelo menos 4
meses, porque ela tem que retreinar
essas mitocôndrias, elas têm que voltar
a conseguir trabalhar com corpos
cetônicos e isso leva tempo, tá? Não é
uma coisa que é rápido,
que o De Bradsen fala de flexibilidade
metabólica, né, que a maioria das
pessoas perdeu pelo menos 70% das
pessoas hoje não têm mais flexibilidade
metabólica por causa da dieta com
excesso de carboidratos. Tem uma
pergunta interessante aqui do Eliseu,
eh, ele tá perguntando sobre crise de
ausência. Você tem algum estudo
específico sobre isso? Que a dieta
cetogênica é tão eficiente quanto as
crises clássicas atônico clônicas quanto
a de ausência ou eles não separam isso?
Eu tô eu não estou lembrando aqui de
nenhum estudo específico, mas crise de
ausência é muito comum, não é? Em
crianças que têm epilepsia, isso,
certo? Então, a gente teria que estudar
caso a caso, mas tem muitos estudos de
doenças eh convulsivas, né, raras, que
atendem muito bem a dieta cetogênica.
Então, teria que estudar caso a caso a
genética também da pessoa, mas se não
está hoje o consenso em epilepsia,
gente, qualquer um deles já testou mais
de três medicamentos e continua tendo
convulsão, tem que testar a dieta
citogênica. Se não é candidato para
neurocirurgia, não tem jeito. Tem que
testar dieta citogênica, não vai deixar
a pessoa.
Inclus. Inclusive, eu até dei essa
orientação recentemente paraa minha
cunhada lá, que tem alguém da família
dela que tem um epilepsia refratário,
falei: "Faz a dieta cetogênica".
Tem que fazer. A gente não tá dizendo
para tirar medicação, tá gente, de
nenhuma doença, nem transtorno mental,
nem câncer, nem epilepsias, nem nada.
Mas tem que combinar, porque a gente
sabe que a combinação com uma série de
fármacos ajuda muito no tratamento.
Joana, a tua resposta é sim, tá? Mas
sempre com complemento médico
nutricional, tá? Você pode se beneficiar
sim se você tem epilepsia da dieta
cetogênica.
Doutor já falou sobre isso durante a
transmissão que caso você não tenha
pego, você pode voltar e a assistir o
vídeo que vai ficar gravado.
A Ninha tá falando assim, ó. Tomar TCM
com químio protege o fígado, na verdade
protege várias células. A gente sabe que
a dieta cetogênica, não só o suplemento
TCM, mas a dieta cetogênica, ela é um
protetor celular contra os efeitos
deletérios da quimioterapia, tá? Então,
por isso, né, uma das recomendações
também de associação da dieta com certos
tipos de cânceres, não todos, mas com
alguns.
Tem um comentário no Instagram, eu não
vou conseguir colocar na tela, mas uma
pessoa comentou sobre o custo do exame
do beta hidróxirato de R$ 600 no Brasil.
Mas não é disso que nós estamos falando,
pessoal. Nós estamos falando de você
monitorar ou com aparelhinho de for ao
dedo ou com CKM, se Deus quiser vai
conseguir entrar no Brasil. que é aquele
monitor contínuo, que é igualzinho
aquele que vocês conhecem de glicose, só
que mede de copos cetônicos, tá? Eh,
você não precisa fazer nenhum exame de
sangue assim pontual no laboratório,
porque também não vai te dar uma
informação muito útil. Você você quer
monitorar o dia a dia, não só uma medida
pontual única que deve tá sendo num
contexto, não imagino que ele tá
falando, num contexto de um exame de
metabolômica, tá? Esse esse caso aí do
da medida do beta do BHB.
H, tem mais uma outra pessoa aqui.
Então, gente, esse aparelhinho que a
gente colocou, né, que a gente monitorou
por 14 dias, ele fica 14 dias no braço,
monitorando minuto a minuto, o dia todo,
24 horas por 14 dias. Ainda não está
disponível no Brasil. Aqui na Europa ele
custa cerca de 60 e poucos euros esse
monitor, tá? Então ele fica o dia todo
monitorando, porque realmente, né, ir no
laboratório todo dia para monitorar,
tirar, colher sangue todo dia para
monitorar não dá. E o exame de
metabolômica também é inviável nesse
sentido de monitoramento contínuo,
porque o exame de metabolômica é um
exame de urina que leva um mês para
ficar pronto, não é? Então também não
faz o menor sentido. Então a gente tá
falando que a gente usou um aparelho de
monitoramento contínuo. Qual seriam as
outras alternativas? Existem
aparelhinhos que avaliam na ponta do
dedo, tá? Então é um outro tipo de
monitoramento. E existe também o
monitoramento com fitinhas de urina, mas
que também não são muito fidedignas.
Então o ideal é no sangue, esse da ponta
do dedo ou monitor contínuo, tá? Esse da
ponta do dedo tem gente que consegue
comprar o aparelhinho mais fácil no
Brasil, né? Às vezes acha na Amazon, no
IHub, em alguma farmácia e tal. Eh, mas
aí tem que ficar furando o dedo. E por
que que é importante monitorar várias
vezes ao dia? Porque vamos supor que
você monitorou de manhã, estava em cetos
vai ficar o dia todo em cetose, Alan?
Como foi com você? Ficava o dia todo em
cetose?
De jeito nenhum. Eu, o que mais me
surpreendeu é que de manhã cedo em jejum
era o horário que eu menos ficava em
cetosa.
Por quê, gente? Porque o cortisol tá lá
em cima, né? Que que é esse cortisol? É
um hormônio que todo mundo produz. É um
hormônio super importante, assim como
todos os hormônios do nosso organismo.
Então, a gente quer hormônio na
quantidade adequada, nem para cima, nem
para baixo. E cada hormônio ele é
produzido num horário para uma função
específica. de manhã, lá paraas 5 da
manhã, a gente começa a produzir
cortisol. O que que o cortisol faz?
Acelera batimento cardíaco, aumenta a
temperatura e pum, nos desperta. Então,
o hormônio do stress nos tira do sono.
Para quê? Pra gente viver da nossa vida.
Que que a gente falou? Quando a gente
tem hormônio de stress circulando,
o hormônio do stress joga açúcar na
corrente sanguínea. Então a gente sai da
cetose, dependendo do tanto de cortisol
que a gente produziu, do tanto de
adrenalina que a gente produziu, tá?
Então isso que ele tá falando. De manhã,
quando eu acordava ia medir, era o
horário que eu tinha menos eh corpo
cetônico e você pensa que vai ter mais
porque você tá mais tempo em jejum, mas
não
tava em jejum.
É, se você tivesse medido 3 da manhã,
provavelmente tava lá em cetos.
de manhã cedinho por conta do cortisol,
às vezes baixou, né?
Exatamente.
Então,
eh, e aí é diferente, gente. Eu e o Alan
não temos nenhuma doença. A gente não
precisa ficar em cetose. A gente fez um
experimento para poder contar para
vocês. É diferente de uma pessoa que
precisa manter a cetose sempre. Então,
essa pessoa não pode sair de cetose e a
dieta dela vai ser diferente, não pode
ter escorregada porque senão ela perde o
efeito. Vou dar um exemplo para vocês.
Eu tava lá cetose, sete dias bonitinho,
cetose alta, tava feliz da vida. Eu
ganhei de presente da vizinha uma caixa
de mirtilos. E eu adoro mirtilos, gente.
Aí eu comi alguns. Eu ainda tava na
dieta cetogênica, mas eu comi alguns
mirtilos. Que que aconteceu? Cetose,
pum, foi lá para baixo. Açúcar. É açúcar
saudável, é açúcar da fruta. É uma fruta
saudável, tem fibra, tem pena.
É uma fruta baixa em carboidrato também,
né?
É uma fruta. Isso aí da cetose, tá?
Então é diferente se fosse um paciente
que precisa manter a cetose para não ter
convulsão, de repente essa queda porque
comeu frota já faria a pessoa voltar a
ter convulsão.
Queria te fazer uma pergunta. O Fernando
Henrique no Instagram perguntou sobre
essa pergunta. sempre vê em todas as
lives, né? Tudo que a gente fala,
pessoal, alguém vai falar: "Ah, isso é
para rico, isso é para rico".
Eu queria que você falasse assim,
independente de comprar CM ou não, a
pessoa que quer fazer uma dieta low carb
ou ultra low carb que seja, qual que é o
jeito assim
de fazer que não vai gastar dinheiro
para esse pessoal que fala que tudo é
tudo é caro, não dá para fazer nada, não
sei o quê? Eu vou até voltar, gente,
naquele naquele slide, porque eu acho
aquele slide bem importante para quem
não chegou no início da aula. Quem tá no
Instagram, gente, quiser ver o slide,
né? Acho que no Instagram também tá
dando para ver.
Ver, mas é, fica pequenininho, tá? Vê
melhor,
fica pequeninino. Mas a primeira coisa,
gente, eh importante é o seguinte, né?
Tem alimentos que a gente come, apareceu
o slide, né? Tem alimentos que a gente
come, né, eh, principalmente os
industrializados, que eles sempre vão
ter um valor maior agregado. É muito
diferente você fazer arroz em casa ou
você comprar arroz no restaurante. No
restaurante vai ser mais caro. É
diferente você fazer ovo em casa ou ir
comer ovo no restaurante? É diferente
você comer carne em casa ou ir comer no
restaurante ou pedir no iFood. sempre
que você vai pedir em algum lugar, tem
um valor agregado e sempre alimento
industrializado tem um valor muito mais
alto. Então a primeira coisa que você
tem que fazer, gente, é o seguinte.
Entra no chat GPT, entra em qualquer
aplicativo desses gratuitos de cálculo
de dieta e bota tudo que você comeu
ontem lá e veja a quantidade de
carboidrato que tem na sua dieta, tá?
Você vai ver que na maioria das pessoas
as pessoas estão comendo 200 g, 300 g,
400 g de carboidrato ao dia, tá? Então a
primeira coisa nem é dieta cetogênica.
Se para todas as faixas etárias a
recomendação é de 130 g de carboidrato e
você não é um atleta de ponta, porque é
que você tá comendo 200, 300, 400, 500 g
de carboidrato ao dia? Então essa é a
primeira para que você tem que fazer,
não é nem pensar em dieta cetogênica. é
ir tirando o superérflos de carboidrato
simples ou industrializado da sua dieta.
Porque se a gente tá precisa para todas
as faixas etárias de 130 g de
carboidrato, essa é a recomendação de
carboidrato para um envelhecimento
saudável. E você em uma refeição como
essa aqui consome 170, tá certo?
Não tá certo. Então, a primeira coisa
que você tem que saber é ter uma noção
de de fato quanto que você consome. E aí
não depende, gente, da da,
né, da da sua renda, porque tem gente
que tem renda muito baixa e tá comendo
muito carboidrato. E tem gente que tem
renda muito alta e também tá comendo
muito carboidrato. Então, você primeiro
tem que ter uma noção quanto de
carboidrato eu tô comendo. E o que disso
aqui não vale a pena eu comer, que todo
aqueles alimentos que todo mundo sabe
que não vai te fazer bem. E aí vamos
tentando melhorar essa qualidade, tá? E
chegando mais perto de 130. Todo mundo
precisa de dieta abaixo de 130? Não. Nem
todo mundo precisa de dieta abaixo de
130. Agora, se você tem alguma dessas
condições de saúde que a gente falou,
obesidade, diabetes, transtornos
mentais, epilepsia, né? eh, Alzheimer,
na família, etc., né? Poxa, vamos
prestar mais atenção. Outra coisa, o que
mais pesa fora os alimentos
industrializados, alimentos
industrializados sempre são mais caros.
Fora os alimentos industrializados, que
vai mais pesar em termos de
grana, vai ser alimento de eh origem
animal, principalmente carnes. As
carnes, carne vermelha vai ter um custo
muito maior na dieta do que outros
alimentos. E aí muita gente, gente,
pensa que dieta cetogênica é dieta
carnívora. Isso não é dieta cetogênica.
Dieta cetogênica é uma dieta que tem
mais gordura. Para vocês terem uma
ideia, quando a gente faz estudos, tem
uma colega minha que acabou de fazer
estudos com epilepsia no SUS e pacientes
do SUS não têm renda alta na maioria das
vezes e por isso estão fazendo
tratamento pelo SUS. Eh, e nesses
pacientes, muitos deles, ela teve que
fazer dieta cetogênica para controlar as
convulsões das crianças. E não é o que a
gente recomenda, tá gente? Porque é uma
dieta inflamatória. Mas o que que é
dieta cetogênica? É uma dieta com muito
mais gordura. Ela teve que usar na dieta
dessas crianças para controlar as
convulsões muito mais óleo vegetal. E o
óleo que a família tinha acesso era óleo
de milho, era óleo de girassol, era óleo
de canola, era óleo de soja, fosse o que
fosse para conseguir controlar as
convulsões. Então quando a gente fala de
dieta cetogênica, é claro que se a
pessoa puder usar uma gordura boa do
azeite, do abacate, do açaí, da
castanha, etc. melhor, mas o
profissional de saúde vai tentar ajustar
de acordo com a possibilidade da pessoa,
obviamente, tá? Então, tem pessoa que
pode suplemento, vai o suplemento. Tem
pessoa que não pode suplemento, não vai
o suplemento. Tem pessoa que pode o
azeite, vai o azeite. Tem pessoa que só
pode soja.
É, isso aí é uma situação até que eu
sinto até uma dor no coração, mas a
pessoa não tem outra opção, né? Tem que
encher a dea de soja. Exatamente. Então,
não é a nossa recomendação, gente, mas é
isso. Dieta cetogênica tira da cabeça.
Dieta cetogênica não é dieta carnívora.
O que a gente tá falando é de uma dieta
cetogênica terapêutica que serve para o
tratamento de condições específicas. É
claro que, por exemplo, Dra. Alan, que
sempre se interessou muito por
Alzheimer, eh, o Alzheimer, ele não é só
uma questão glicolítica cerebral. tem o
componente neuroinflamatório, tem o
componente oxidativo, tem tantos
componentes o Alzheimer, né? Então, se
fosse só, por exemplo, glicolítico, eu
botava óleo de soja e tava resolvido.
Mas tem o componente neuroinflamatório
que eu não trato com óleo de soja, então
preciso de uma gordura maior, melhor,
não é? Então, é claro que a gente vai
ter que ajustar de caso a caso, mas
isso, ó, cada um precisa discutir com o
seu profissional de saúde, tá?
H, tem uma pergunta sobre a lulose. Você
tem experiência com adoçante a lulose?
Eu não tenho experiência por com a
lulose, gente, porque quando eu saí do
Brasil a lulose não estava disponível e
em Portugal, que é onde eu moro, ainda é
proibido, tá? Então, eu sei que tem
vários estudos com a lulose já,
inclusive para dieta cetogênica, eh, mas
eu nunca usei. E é lógico, né, quando
você considera eh adoçantes artificiais,
eles são péssimos, inclusive pro
cérebro, né? Então, a gente sempre vai
na tentativa de ir para doçantes mais
naturais possíveis, que não ten sabor
residual, etc. Agora, na dieta
cetogênica, eh, quando a gente pode
tirar todo tipo de coisa agregada,
melhora, até porque a lulose mesmo, para
quem tem acesso é um adoçante caro. Eh,
então, eh, quando a pessoa pode aprender
a tomar o café sem nada, é muito melhor
do que com café com qualquer tipo de
adoçante. Porque mesmo quando a gente
fala assim, esse adoçante é seguro, é
seguro de acordo com o que a gente sabe
hoje, né, gente? Mas não é uma coisa
natural aí que a gente encontra eh e que
o ser humano sempre tomou e cada vez
mais aparecem estudos de efeitos
adversos com cada tipo de adoçante que a
gente vai colocando na dieta, né? Então
eu não tenho experiência nenhuma com a
lulose porque não não é acessível para
mim, tá? Nem era no Brasil e agora
também não é aqui em Portugal, não tem
aqui em Portugal. Eh, mas é um adoçante
que que é considerado zero caloria, né?
Porque ele tem 0,2
calorias por gama. né? E quando você
compara com açúcar, então a lulose 02
por gama e açúcar 4 por gama, tá? Mas eu
não tenho exper
esse estudo, mas tem estudos com
adoçantes mais convencionais que mostram
só o fato da pessoa pôr uma coisa doce
na boca já bagunça toda a questão
neuromonal das encretinas do intestino.
Então não vale a pena ficar assim. Eu
recomendo os pacientes usar ou monk
fruit ou o stevia puro, se não dá conta
de ficar com sabor doce como quebra
galho, mas o ideal é você cortar tudo,
porque senão você fica estimulando os
receptores na boca de de doce, mesmo que
não tenha caloria, isso bagunça as
encretinas lá do intestino, tá?
Isso causa, sabe aquela história, gente?
Sabe aquela história de obeso que só
toma refrigerante diet e continua obeso?
Exatamente,
né? É
porque você vai, né, aquele aquele sabor
doce vai se ligar em vários receptores e
toda vez que você ativa receptor tem uma
mensagem pro cérebro. Para que que serve
o sabor doce? Para avisar pro cérebro,
olha, vai entrar calorias, se prepara
que vai entrar açúcar. Qual que é uma
das respostas do cérebro? Falar pro
pâncreas. Pâncreas vai entrar açúcar, a
gente tem que tratar disso. E aí o
pâncreas produz insulina. Se você manda
essa mensagem pro cérebro, vai entrar
açúcar. O cérebro fala pro pâncreas
produzir um monte de insulina e não
entra açúcar, o que que vai acontecer,
gente? Você vai ter uma hipoglicemia,
sua glicose vai lá no chão. Qual que é o
primeiro sintoma de hipoglicemia antes
de você ficar tonto e antes de você
desmaiar? fome,
teve hipoglicemia, você tem fome. Então
você tomou refrigerante diet, mas vai
comer uma coxinha, vai emagrecer,
não vai continuar obeso.
Não, fora, mesmo que não começa a a a
coxinha, só de aumentar insulina tá
inflamando o teu corpo, né? E tá
causando resistência insulina, né?
Exatamente. A Ninha tá falando assim:
"Explica o que seria glicolítico, gente.
Glicolítico é uma palavra que vem de
glicose. Que que é glicose? é o açúcar
que a gente usa, né, que que circula no
nosso sangue. Essa é a glicose. Nossas
células têm uma facilidade de utilizar a
glicose, só que com o envelhecimento,
com os desajustes da dieta, com as
alterações hormonais, com a falta de
sono, a gente vai ficando com cada vez
mais dificuldade
de usar esse açúcar. E aí vai dando
aquela barriguinha, vai dando aquela
névoa cerebral, vamos aumentando de
peso, os hormônios vão desregulando.
Então a gente fala que nesse momento
está tendo uma alteração
do metabolismo glicolítico, uma
alteração da forma como a célula
consegue usar açúcar. Antes era algo que
ela usava super bem, não é? Quando a
gente era criança, a gente comia bolo e
chocolate e sei lá o quê, tudo com
açúcar e tava tudo bem. Depois de uma
fase já não está tudo bem, porque a
gente alterou muito o metabolismo, não
é? Hoje a recomendação pra criança da
gente dar zero de açúcar paraa criança,
não é para ficar dando açúcar pra
criança, porque a gente sabe que vai
pagar as consequências lá na frente, né?
Então, eh, muitas doenças têm uma
alteração
relacionada a metabolismo glicolítico,
como Alzheimer, como diabetes, como
transtorno bipolar, como alguns
subgrupos de pessoas com autismo e assim
por diante. Então, para corrigir esse
metabolismo glicolítico, existem
remédios,
existem, tem efeitos colaterais, um
monte. E existem estudos com estratégias
naturais pra gente reverter o diabetes,
pra gente reverter a velocidade ou
desacelerar a velocidade de
neurodegeneração e assim por diante.
Então, um dos estudos, um dos caminhos
são as dietas com menos carboidrato,
menos de 130 g ao dia, entendeu? Mas
assim, gente, tem toda a individualidade
bioquímica, genética. acompanhem no meu
Instagram, porque todo dia eu falo de
estudo genético, né, inclusive dos meus,
né, para vocês entenderem, né, não
funciona igual para todo mundo, né,
dependem de muitos fatores e por isso
que a gente tem que se aconselhar com
profissionais que entendam, né, da área,
porque não dá para ficar fazendo também
um monte de experimento na gente e
degradando a saúde, né, piorando a
saúde. Tem um comentário do Eliseu aqui,
ele tá perguntando quando esse medidor
de cetose
eh vai chegar ao Brasil, né? Aí eu
queria que você falasse sobre a o
monitoramento que nós estamos fazendo,
né? A prospecção que nós estamos fazendo
para entender se é o momento da gente
Uhum.
verificar isso, né? Vocês sabem, né,
gente, que importar qualquer coisa pro
Brasil tem vários eh constrangimentos,
né, várias dificuldades.
Eh, então, se você vai comprar um
computador nos Estados Unidos, ele custa
X, vai comprar o mesmo computador no
Brasil, custa 2x, 3x, né? tem muito
imposto, tem muitas questões
tributárias, então não é fácil essa
importação, mas a gente tem a intenção
de levar isso ao Brasil e a gente tá eh
fazendo muitas discussões, né, com a
empresa produtora desses monitores. Eh,
mas estamos tentando, né, vencer essas
barreiras e e vendo de que forma a gente
pode ajudar, porque existe um grupo
muito grande de pessoas que demandam,
né, por doenças graves, inclusive que
precisariam estar monitorando para se
proteger. Mas a gente ainda não tem
resposta quanto a isso, sabe? A gente
gostaria de levar esse ano. Vamos
tentar, mas eh não podemos prometer
ainda,
não. Sem dúvida. Inclusive, tem um
questionário que a gente tá criando para
saber o interesse das pessoas sobre
isso, pra gente entender se vale a pena
a gente dar seguimento a essa ideia, né?
Uhum.
Porque existe muita gente que já conhece
as confusões aqui do do Brasil, né?
Muitas empresas internacionais que t
sede na Ásia ou na Europa sabem do
ambiente ruim que existe no Brasil com
relação a esse tipo de importação, né?
Então existe muita relutância de
empresas internacionais de entrar no
Brasil por conta disso. Então a gente tá
tentando entender,
o Brasil, né? O Brasil é muito grande,
né, gente? Então o o a própria
distribuição, né, não é não é tão fácil,
mas a gente a gente gostaria muito de
ter porque a gente sabe que beneficiaria
uma quantidade muito grande de pacientes
nossos que precisam muito. Eu trabalho
com muitos pacientes com câncer de
cérebro, o Alan e outros profissionais
trabalham muito com Alzheimer, tem
muitos pacientes com diabetes que se
beneficiariam até para fazer a dieta
cetogênica com segurança, sabe, gente?
sem desenvolver nenhum outro problema de
saúde, sem ter eh hipoglicemias que
estão falando aí, sem ter eh enfim, uma
série de questões e para que seja
realmente de benefício, porque se a
pessoa também tá fazendo a dieta
cetogênica toda errada e não tá
atingindo os níveis de cetose que ela
precisa, ela tá fazendo um grande
esforço, restringindo tantas vezes a
alimentação sem ter benefício nenhum.
Então é nossa intenção realmente levar e
a gente tá se esforçando para isso. A
gente tá tendo muitas reuniões com a
empresa produtora, né, tentando eh mas a
gente também precisa saber de vocês, né?
Vocês conhecem pessoas que se
interessam, vocês se interessam nesse
aparelho. Eh, e e de fato a gente ainda
não produz no Brasil e alguém falou, né?
Poxa, é coisa de rico. Infelizmente não
é uma coisa barata mesmo, né? Cuidar da
saúde não é não está sendo barato em
nenhuma área e a gente tá tendo que
encarar realmente como um investimento,
cada um na sua saúde, né, gente, para
para envelhecer melhor, envelhecer de
forma autônoma, porque imagina gente a
gente envelhecer em cima de uma cama,
envelhecer dependendo dos outros.
Sim, sim. Mas separar as coisas aqui
porque assim, é óbvio que um monitor
desse não vai ficar barato no Brasil,
independente de quem vai trazer para cá,
tá? Esse é um ponto. Segundo ponto, ah,
mas eu não tenho condições, tal, tal.
OK? Você não tem condições, mas você
pode comer natural. Comer natural você
já tá fazendo um grande benefício paraa
tua saúde. Cobe o que vem da granja, o
que vem da do açogue, o que vem da
feira, tu já tá fazendo grande benefício
para tua saúde. Ah, mas não precisa se
estupir de carne, como ela falou, carne
é cara de modo geral, no mundo inteiro,
né? O Brasil talvez seja até mais barato
que a maior parte do mundo, né? A carne.
Então assim, você quer economizar, ah,
mas o ovo tá caro também. Ovo já foi
mais barato, eu sei disso, né? Mas você
consegue ter proteína vegetal, proteína
do ovo, você vai se virando, você não
vai monitorar a acetose. Mas o que eu
percebi nesses 14 dias, eh, é que
realmente você, sabe aquela aquele meme
do puf, né?
Dão tantos insightes, não é?
Não, porque você, eu já tinha feito a
dieta citogênica anos atrás, eu tinha
emagrecido barbaridade, né? Eh, até
demais. Eu fiquei com a cara meio
encovada na época.
Eh, com monitoramento da da dos copos
setor é outra história. É como se você
tivesse navegando a esmo pelo mar e de
repente alguém te dá um GPS.
É, e assim, para quem tem doença, esse
monitoramento é muito importante, porque
até isso, né, eu fiz há anos atrás e a
minha experiência foi diferente. Então,
até isso, né, gente? Eh, a Andreia de 10
anos atrás tinha um metabolismo
totalmente diferente da Andreia agora de
51 anos, sabe? Então, eh, o que
funcionava também naquela época não
necessariamente funciona agora, né?
Então, o monitoramento ajuda muito a
gente entender o que tá acontecendo. Não
só monitoramento de cetonas, né, gente?
Todo mundo tem que manter os exames em
dia. Tem gente que não, nunca fez um
exame de homocisteína na vida e já tem
50 anos. É outro fator de risco para
doença cardiovascular, para doença
mental, para doença neurodegenerativa,
para tantas coisas, né? Então, esses
monitoramentos básicos, né, eh, são
muito importantes e por isso que a gente
fica nas redes sociais enchendo o saco
de vocês, né, para se cuidarem, porque
se cada um não assumir as rédeas da sua
saúde, quando a gente vai ver, a coisa
bagunçou de um nível que às vezes a
gente não consegue corrigir mais.
É. E aí aquela argumentação de que, ah,
não faço tal coisa porque é caro, você
vai gastar muito mais lá na frente com
tratamentos aí, hospitais e, né, fora o
tempo que você vai ficar sem trabalhar e
não vai ganhar dinheiro porque você tá
doente, né? Então é, tem que tem que
colocar essas coisas sempre em
perspectiva, né, que as pessoas são
muito rápidas nessa história de falar
que não tem dinheiro,
quando na verdade elas não sabem
priorizar o dinheiro delas, né, por
causa de influência de rede social, a
pessoa coloca o foco dela nas coisas
erradas, né? Ah, eu preciso ficar
bancando James Bond, viajando no mundo
inteiro, mas não tem dinheiro para
cuidar da saúde, por exemplo, né?
É, a gente sempre bate nas mesmas
teclas, né? A gente tem algumas coisas
que são base para saúde. Outro dia uma
pessoa falou assim: "André, eu tô muito
cansada, será que é anemia?" Eu falei:
"Ou é anemia ou Instagram, porque você
não sai desse Instagram, tem que dormir,
não é? Se não for anemia, Instagram, não
é?" Então assim, tem as coisas são
básicas. Dormir, você tá dormindo o
tanto que você precisa, né? Porque sem
dormir não adianta o melhor monitor do
mundo, tá? tem que dormir. Eh, se você
tá acordando todo dia se arrastando, seu
metabolismo não vai ficar legal, né? Tá
fazendo o mínimo de atividade física,
nem que seja e andar na rua, caminhar na
rua, né? Tem que fazer atividade física
na maioria dos dias da semana, tá?
Tirando os industrializados da dieta,
esse é o mínimo, né? Tira de o
industrializado da dieta, né? Então, tem
aqueles mínimos que a gente tem que
fazer. Um é movimento, outro é sono e
outro é dieta. Não tem jeito, né? Não
tem jeito mesmo. Só pra gente,
básico primeiro, né? Oi.
Faço o básico primeiro.
Sim, tem que fazer o básico primeiro,
gente. Fez o básico, aí depois você se
preocupa o que que é caro, que que é
barato, né? As pessoas querem pular logo
pro nível cinco se não fizeram o nível
um, né?
Esse que é o problema da maioria das
pessoas aí. Ah, tão perguntando para
Finalizar aqui.
Oi.
É, pode falar.
Eu ia finalizar como a última pergunta.
Ah, sim, sim. Tudo bem. Você tá com
compromisso?
Tô, tô.
Tá. Vamos encerrar aqui. Eh, como é que
a dieta citogênica ajuda uma mulher na
menopause? Vamos responder essa última
aqui, tá? E a o questionário, você não
tinha um questionário que você queria
dividir o link com a gente?
Vamos. Você consegue colocar aí no chat
enquanto eu enquanto eu respondo
pergunta, coloca no comentário aqui no
você tá no você tá no YouTube.
Deixa eu pegar aqui então o
questionário.
Ou então você me manda no WhatsApp. Ou
então você manda no WhatsApp que eu
coloco aqui na tela, pessoal. Depois eu
coloco na na descrição do vídeo.
Isso. Mas eu vou botar aqui porque eu já
achei. Eh, mas para finalizar, gente, em
relação a à dieta cetogênica, então, né?
Eh, há alguns anos atrás eu fui num
congresso na Suíça e eu conheci os
grandes pesquisadores da dieta
cetogênica e foi, inclusive assim eh um
congresso muito importante para mim,
porque eh eu tinha ainda, né, eh muito
preconceito com a dieta cetogênica e só
usava cetogênica realmente para tratar
eh epilepsia, mais nada, tá? e tinha
realmente muita dificuldade com dieta
cetogênica nos outros campos. Mas nesse
estudo eu eu conheci não só
pesquisadores incríveis e histórias
incríveis, né? Por exemplo, eu conheci o
Dr. Alan, eh, o Dr. Ian Campbell, que é
um pesquisador, um neurocientista que
tem transtorno bipolar e ele começou a
usar o o a dieta cetogênica com ele,
porque ele não aguentava mais tanta
medicação, ele só vivia internado, né?
tinha já muita ideiação suicida e tudo.
E aí ele começou a usar a dieta
cetogênica, ele melhorou muito de
milhões de medicamentos, ele reduziu
para apenas um, tá? Então ele continua
com uma medicação, mas apenas uma em vez
de 10. E ele ficou tão impressionado com
isso que ele começou a estudar a dieta
cetogênica. ele voltou pra universidade,
se formou em neurologia e e começou a
estudar dieta cetogênica nos pacientes
deles. E foi muito emocionante esse
congresso, porque ele começou a resgatar
pessoas que moravam na rua, né? Então,
pessoas que tinham transtornos mentais,
que não tinham nenhum apoio familiar,
perdiam trabalho por conta do transtorno
mental, não tinha dinheiro, não tinha
como pagar aluguel, acontecia o quê?
Virava morador de rua. E ele começou a
resgatar várias dessas pessoas e levar
para perto dele, fazer dieta cetogênica.
E uma das pessoas que ele resgatou dessa
situação de rua, gente, virou
nutricionista e trabalha hoje com ele
com dieta cetogênica. Então assim, para
mim, né, vê aquele depoimento e aquela
menina falando, a menina linda, sabe,
morando na rua por conta de um
transtorno mental que não tinha
tratamento, né? Não, os remédios não
funcionavam. Para mim aquilo foi tão
emocionante, ó, até hoje meu olho enche
de lágrima, porque foi tão emocionante
como uma dieta pode resgatar uma pessoa
que eu passei a estudar muito isso, né,
a dieta cetogênica. E lá nesse congresso
eu conheci uma das nutricionistas que
treinam todos esses médicos no mundo
inteiro. Inclusive depois eu fiz uma uns
cursos com ela e na época que eu conheci
essa nutricionista,
ela estava entrando na menopausa. Eu
ainda não tinha entrado na menopausa,
mas ela já tinha entrado. E ela mesma,
ela ensinava todo mundo a fazer dieta
cetogênica, mas ela mesma não fazia
dieta cetogênica, né? mulher magra,
comia bem, tava tudo bem. E quando ela
entrou na menopausa, ela tinha calorões
assim horríveis, horríveis, horríveis,
horríveis. E aí ela resolveu fazer a
dieta cetogênica e acabou os fogachos
dela, né? Então hoje ela também trabalha
com dieta cetogênica na menopausa para
regulação de temperatura, regulação de
inflamação e etc, né? Então, existe
também esse campo hoje da dieta
cetogênica eh para regulação hormonal,
tá? Não é o campo que eu trabalho, mas
uma pergunta muito interessante.
Olha, eu coloquei o link na tela e na
verdade é um link que eu criei para
porque aquele outro link que ela é um
link, aqueles link todo complicado,
cheio de letra. Aí para facilitar eu
coloquei esse link aí que vai pro mesmo
lugar.
Deixa eu ver se eu consigo colocar um
Qcode na tela aqui para vocês. Pera aí.
Só para, só para complementar, gente, o
nome dessa nutricionista que eu falei,
né? É que é a maior nutricionista de
cetogênica do mundo, é a Beth Zupecânia,
né? Então, a nutricionista que treinou
tudo quanto é médico. Eu fiz tratamento
com ela, ela treina todos os
nutricionistas, é a pessoa que mais
antiga pesquisa assim na nutrição eh
dieta cetogênica. Ela começou
pesquisando nas epilepsias há décadas
atrás e hoje é uma mulher um pouco mais
velha do que eu, mas hoje trabalha
também na área de saúde mental,
inclusive na área de menopausa, com
grande sucesso.
Beleza, eu coloquei o link tanto nos
comentários aqui do vídeo ao vivo,
depois eu vou colocar na versão que vai
permanecer, que vai ficar gravada, no na
descrição e no comentário fixado. E esse
QR code que vocês estão vendo aí no
canto esquerdo da tela, não sei se tá
aparecendo, não, não tá aparecendo no
Instagram não, porque tá o Instagram tem
menos espaço, mas enfim, vocês podem
usar o Qcode também para entrar no
questionário pra gente entender quantas
pessoas estariam interessadas nisso. Daí
deixa eu só ver se eu tirar da tela aqui
o
Deixa eu tirar isso aqui para aparecer
só o Qcode no Instagram também. Bem,
pessoal, só responde só a última
pergunta, André, por favor, que é do se
a dieta citogênica pode ajudar na
menopausa, a gente vai encerrar, tá bom?
Isso, acabei de responder. Então, foi a
Dra. Zupecânia, BCK Zupec Cânia, que
estuda isso,
isso. E ela tem grande sucesso no
tratamento da menopausa com a dieta
cetogênica.
Tá, joia, eu tava preocupado com QR code
aqui, não prestei atenção suficiente.
Vou ter que ver depois o o vídeo
gravado.
Sem problemas, sem problemas,
pessoal. Então é isso, agradeço
imensamente a presença de vocês. A live
começou a ficar bem movimentada depois
das 11:40, então isso já é um sinal, viu
André? Se a gente fizer novamente, nós
precisamos fazer um pouquinho mais
tarde, fazer por volta do meio-dia aqui
do Brasil, que 11 horas o pessoal ainda
tá
meio que acordando ainda. Muita gente tá
acordando ainda.
Não tem problema, tem pessoal que vai
assistir gravado. Olha, foi um prazer
estar com vocês. Obrigado para quem
acompanhou a gente, para quem fez
perguntas, aliás, perguntas super
interessantes. Fico contente com o
engajamento de vocês e
um abraço. Até a próxima.
Um abraço a todos vocês. Até a próxima.
Ótimo domingo a todos. Ótima semana.